[Music]
heidi is with us in atlanta hey heidi
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for having me and talking to
me today how are you
sure what's up
um
i'm in a little bit of a predicament um
i'm coming to the realization that i'm
having to possibly make some
decisions that are not only financially
i'm having trouble understanding you can
you speak directly into your phone
please
sounds muffled hey
are you
can you hear me now yes ma'am a little
better go ahead and try again
tuck bolt
um yeah it's just you and me and dave
like 10 million other people it's good
yeah exactly
um i can't speak too loudly because my
husband's downstairs and i don't want to
be interrupted by him
um
so i'm in a situation where um
my husband's not wanting to work on our
finances together
um this last two and a half years he has
not been contributing towards our joint
account at all
money is completely separated and uh
recently he informed me that
um if i want my financial situation to
change i have to do something
about it um because i've suggested to
him i've been listening to you for the
last
month or so here and talking about how
if we're going to get out of that we
need to work on it together
i sent him
different shows that you've
released and in order for him to listen
to it he's just not on board with it
um why i had
i'm sorry why does he not want to
combine your finances
um
he says that he's got a plan in place
that works for him and um
it does not include you
yeah
so how long has he been having an affair
yeah
um our finances basically have been
always separated
that wasn't wrong
i
i don't know of any
particular situation where
he is having an affair
are you safe
um yeah in my home i'm okay i just
can't speak loudly okay
you can't what can't speak loudly
um so
you just called two guys
listening to how you are having to speak
in your own home
out of fear of a man
who calls himself your husband
and i need you to hear from me who's
also a husband sitting next to another
guy who's a husband
that safety can come in the form of
physical safety and it can also come in
the form of psychological safety where
you don't feel welcome in your own house
and dave's question about
is he having an affair i need you to
hear
hear the behavior
hear what your husband's trying to tell
you through his behavior
that is you are not a priority his
priorities are somewhere else
and he is disinterested in
a relationship with you
correct
right
and it's heartbreaking and i'm saying it
real direct and i know that's hard um
but you are not safe
at all you know that right i'm not
telling anything you don't know you know
that right
yes i know that and this is part of
the last four months has been very
leveling
there you go and so dave's question
about an affair that that was that'd be
my first question too something has
changed in this marriage it was already
separate and we already would have poked
at you for having different accounts
something else has changed either he's
about to leave or he already has left
or something has shifted or he's in
trouble he's got an addiction issue
something else has shifted he's in love
with something else
right
um
his phone
um politics
there's a lot of
different things that are distracting
him but we are all in the same house
together we ever since covered including
the kids
how many children do you have
two girls and what is your income
well
right now it's not where it could be um
it's about 40 000
what could it be
if i went back to my
former career that i left to try to do
this rv life with him
um i could be making upwards of 90
on my own
so maybe what she could be making
upwards of 90 on her oh 90. i didn't
hear the 90. okay i'm sorry and um
how old are your children
13 and 9.
can i ask you a real hard question
yes
is this the picture
of
love that you want to communicate to
them
no it's not and that's i mean i've been
you know wrestling with this like i said
for the last four months and after
speaking to some of my friends and
coming to the realization that
you know not only is it financial abuse
it's my mental health it's my children's
mental health
it's all of it it's this is not the
person my parents raised
um
my dad i was completely i bought this
house on my own single
um i was completely debt free when i got
married
and that has changed okay and i want to
get back to who i was before yeah so
here's what you're gonna have to do
um your friends aren't who walk through
you with this except as friends but you
need to get a good counselor yes so you
need to go see a marriage counselor
starting today
that is a strong person that will try to
help you save your marriage if it's
salvageable
that will give you some verbage and some
positions to remind you you're not crazy
because you got two guys here saying
you're not crazy
okay and we're both we both know this
stuff okay
so um you need to get a counselor that
can guide you through this you don't
want to do this off of a radio call and
you don't want to do this off of your
friend's opinion over a glass of wine
you need to get a counselor in your
corner that can give you some ways to
explain to your husband
that will amount to ultimately an
ultimatum a boundary a boundary that
says you are going to re-engage
or you're going to disengage we're not
going to play here in the middle
and i'm not going to be abused at this
level anymore
and you got to have someone help you set
that boundary not two guys on the radio
but you're not crazy and you need to do
this and you need to do this right now
john we got to go back to that last
caller for a second uh because there's a
whole lot of that
in america today yeah okay there's a lot
of different ways that husbands and
wives
interact
over money
there's a situation where they work
together and everything's combined
and they make decisions together and
when they make decisions on their
spending and they're investing they
realize that they are truly adding a
level of unity a level of oneness to
their relationship level of
communication their relationship and
that's plan a
and it has the highest probability of
increasing the quality of your marriage
and in the highest probability of you
becoming wealthy plan a does
plan b
is to healthy mentally mature
emotionally mature people who operate
financially like roommates
but both of them have a vote and there
is a mutual respect and there's
communication between them but they run
separate accounts that's a plan b
there's a that lowers the probability of
wealth building and the quality of the
marriage substantially
but it still functions
plan c that's even worse is
uh
mom or dad husband or wife one of the
two is in charge
and the other one is doled out money
as an allowance well i gotta check with
mama see if i gain money
[Music]
meaning the wife is in charge of the
money or i gotta ask my husband because
he handles all the money
and uh or you know we don't i don't know
if we i don't know what we've got and
they die the one that handles the money
dies and the other one just left
clueless
and with no skills because they don't
have decades of handling anything they
basically are a glorified child being
taken care of by an unglorified parent
yeah
in that setting and that is damaging to
the relationship and it's really
damaging to the money really damaging
the money
that
plan f where you fail the test
is one toxic member
of the team
is in control of the money and the other
person it's finance that's abuse with
toxic financial abuse right
the extreme of that
is there's a high correlation
in the data and in the actual practice
and i've seen it on the financial side
i've talked with other coaches you and i
have talked about this uh you probably
can cite a study i've just talked to
other people that have seen it in
practice that if if a husband has
extreme control
over the finances
to the point that the wife is not
allowed to make any can't go the grocery
store by herself she can't pay any
electric bill she's given two dollars at
a time
not two thousand dollars at a time
uh extreme control
probably 90 to 95 percent of the time
he's hitting her
domestic violence tied to that if
there's that level of control you can
just about count on it that last one
gets really close to that that's what my
first question was are you safe right
because you feel it she wanted to say
safe with emotional abuse but she's
upstairs and can't speak loudly because
he's downstairs that's right which makes
me wonder about that whole thing and how
many calls have we taken you and i have
taken that have a couple on they
disagree they're either laughing about
it or they're ingest but serious
that's the first one of these where
somebody's hiding upstairs saying
uh
help
it's
not yeah it's not the first one sadly
but it won't be the last one but the
point of us bringing this up is um i
mean to outline what a plan is b plan is
c plan is and f plan is
um
here's the thing
every one of those regardless of who you
are and which player you are in that
role is a choice to go forward that way
right
and i would encourage every one of you
to choose to move towards the a plan
yeah
um or if you are unsafe to choose to get
out yeah
uh whether you're unsafe emotionally or
you're unsafe physically i don't i don't
tell people to file a divorce and i'll
tell people file bankruptcy but there
are situations where you're unsafe you
need to get out there and if you find
yourself she mentioned something at the
end of that call that
just buried itself in my heart a little
bit she said
this isn't who i am
i i've looked up i bought this house i
bought it on my own i had a great career
i was debt free
and now i'm somebody else that's common
a
language of somebody who's in an abusive
relationship i've become somebody else
in order to keep myself safe keep my
kids cave keep this guy from don't keep
his rage keep his rage down that's right
that's right and when you look in the
mirror and say who are you who have you
become because there's a rage person in
your life that is signal number one call
somebody and get some help right away
yep
yeah
absolutely that's um
the the wrathful man
proverbs talks about is a dangerous
character god amen it's a dangerous
character and um
uh and the sad thing is is that he's
probably has very little coping skills
himself and that's what drives him to
rage that's right yeah and he's get
something i'd love for him to get some
help as well and she mentioned something
the number of calls i'm taking dave on
my show the number the data is bearing
it out the folks over the last 24 months
who have gotten
psychotic about their cell phones
and new data and new information and
news uh
it's destroying people put your phones
down and say i got a problem and go
re-engage or call it you get a human
being get a counselor yes you do not
need your sk put your turn your stupid
screen off and get around human beings
i mean it's uh screen time
uh people have gone down the conspiracy
theory or
alternate theory or whatever you want to
call it uh rabbit hole and they live
there they live they've moved in yeah
yeah and so i've had to put up a
boundary in my life i've got a certain
number of acquaintances slash friends
that i'm like
not here yeah i'm not i'm not talking
about cove anymore i'm tired of it there
you go it's not it's no longer fun i
don't want to talk about anymore yeah
because you're all stupid all of your
stuff
i'm just not talking about anymore you
know
and uh if i die from it y'all just y'all
make fun of me then that's fine but it's
all good and you can be mad at dave
ramsey and you're already mad at him so
screw it you know whatever it's okay so
um but i mean this whole thing you've
got a
this rage that has welled up inside of
the started with a quarantine
and has driven people the fear off of
that it's an existential crisis of
another kind it is and we are feeling a
mass
psychosis man we've got
dude and this is how nonsense gets
started dave that you can't wheel back
and so i want people to put their phones
down and go call a friend call and
ask your close buddies if i've been
raged out and if they're good friends
they'll be honest with you say no or
they'll look you out and say yeah we've
been worried about you yeah i've had
those moments in my life man well you
get in fight mode and you stay jacked up
and you never get off you just go
looking for the next fight the next
fight the next fight yeah and it's a
jacked up thing and then all you do is
just keep fox news on or cnn on
whichever version you are and they'll
feed it to you and they'll make sure
you're pissed off all 24 7. that's how
they get paid exactly and uh and if not
you can turn on your local news and a
tornado's gonna kill you but yeah
oh my god
there's a snowstorm
it's like oh geez
let's get in the truck and drive to work
or don't but pick one don't be ain't
gonna be don't but don't don't don't
don't
turn it about it turn the tv off turn it
off it's white powder it's gonna be okay
ah we all right and so um
yeah and but the the wussification
of america this idea that we don't know
how to fight through something and then
when we get into this
we don't have the the we don't have the
character structure to fight like a man
and still we fight like a boy um
instead of
manly righteous anger it's something
that's truly principled and wrong
and so you become an activist god help
you because you don't have anything else
to do
you know it's just it's weird it's weird
it's happening out there and so if
you're in those situations folks get
some help call somebody please call
somebody get somebody in your corner
walk you walk you out of it and put the
phone down
this is the ramsey show